all around the world and particularly
here in Los Angeles people are mourning
the tragic loss yesterday
of Kobe Bryant his daughter and seven
other people and many of the people who
work here at our show have grown up in
this city Kobe was their hero and I've
been talking to a lot of people on my
staff today that are you know just
devastated and just listening to the
coverage so much is rightly being said
about Kobe's incredible gifts as an
athlete and his prowess on the
basketball court but what I wanted to do
is just take a moment here the top of
the show to highlight another aspect of
Kobe's talent he was naturally very
funny and charming he really was he was
yeah terrific guest and you know a
superstar does not have to be a great
gas and he just was whenever he was on
our show he was a joy to talk with and
he always had the audience in the palm
of his hand that's the guy that I've
been thinking about these past 24 hours
and it's that memory that I would like
to share with you tonight
let's talk about your game face a lot of
people talking about the Kobe Bryant we
have a picture here and you can
I don't understand like how much I
wanted this thing no you know like when
you play like all your motions just pour
out and then that face have to be able
to express yourself fortunately for me I
speak several languages so they don't
know what the hell I'm saying yelling
another languages cooler than any
narrows day how nice is it to be Kobe
Bryant in Los Angeles that's just gonna
be you know great I'm not be here now or
what 15 years yeah so you know this is
uh look everywhere you go I bet you go
to an in-and-out burger they start
chanting they go crazy they love you
everywhere you go
must be fantastic as long as long as
they get my burger race all good I was
talking to two Derek Fisher a teammate
and he said I know if it's true that
Phil Jackson lights up branches of sage
and walks around with like a burning
sage branch to spread the fumes around
the locker room is that true first of
all first of all we don't know if it's
actually sage yeah you guys just played
a tough game against the Celtics a lot
of people just want to know when you're
out there with Shaquille O'Neal when
you're out there with Shaq does he try
and trash talk you does he try and get
inside your head what's it like at this
point no not at all
no I mean he say anything to you if you
did I wouldn't understand him anyway
[Applause]